hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la continua llegada de migrantes a chile
tensa los ánimos en el país en los
últimos días las calles de las zonas de
frontera han sido escenario del rechazo
a los extranjeros y aunque la pandemia y
una nueva ley migratoria más estricta ha
hecho que miles de migrantes salgan de
chile' lo cierto es que a diario otros
cientos ingresan al territorio el
gobierno intenta dar respuesta a la
situación pero las medidas son
insuficientes y causan debate durante
los últimos diez años chile fue el sueño
de quienes buscaban mejores
oportunidades pero ahora el que fuera un
paraíso para los migrantes dejó de serlo
chile fue durante años sinónimo de
esperanza para los migrantes
atraídos por su fuerte economía y la
estabilidad política miles de personas
decidieron cruzar fronteras y
aventurarse hacia el país austral tanto
que se convirtió en imán para los
extranjeros que buscaban mejores
condiciones de vida en la nación hay
casi un millón quinientos mil migrantes
provenientes de diferentes países lo que
equivale al 7 por ciento de la población
según datos del servicio jesuita a
migrantes los venezolanos son los más
numerosos pero también residen peruanos
haitianos y colombianos los venezolanos
que viven de la crisis siguen llegando
en busca de nuevas oportunidades
muchos de ellos entran por la frontera
con perú y bolivia la mayor cantidad de
haitianos llegaron entre 2016 y 2017
cuando se les permitía entrar como
turistas sin visa y regularizar luego su
situación si encontraban trabajo tal fue
el número de migrantes que ingresó que
en abril de 2018 el gobierno chileno
abrió la posibilidad para que cientos
regularizarán su situación jurídica
porque no da la oportunidad porque tú
sabes cuando dejas tu país
a niños pequeños para un porvenir
pero no lo tiene en su país
la medida excedió las expectativas del
gobierno que retrocedió pidiendo visas
consulares y en 2021 comenzó a regir una
nueva ley de migraciones como respuesta
a la llegada masiva de la última década
además inició un proceso de
deportaciones
la meta es expulsar a 1.500 personas
durante 2021 una medida que le ha valido
críticas al gobierno chileno por parte
de organizaciones humanitarias ante
falta de garantías no estoy de acuerdo
porque todos venimos acá con cesión de
trabajar de estabilizarlo de tener un
buen futuro y que no vayan a deportar no
lo conseguimos
en los últimos meses miles de haitianos
decidieron emigrar nuevamente esta vez
desde chile hacia el norte del
continente la falta de trabajo que
empeoró por la pandemia y la nueva ley
los llevaron a tomar la decisión
según el ministerio del interior de
chile si bien la salida de haitianos del
país aumentó un 81 por ciento con
respecto a 2020 la cantidad de migrantes
en el país sigue siendo alta
las calles han sido el termómetro que
evidencia los sentimientos hacia la
migración en chile- mientras un grupo de
exige la salida del país de los
extranjeros otros apoyan su estadía el
punto en común es que piden acciones al
gobierno del presidente sebastián piñera
veamos lo sucedido en el siguiente
informe
en la localidad costera de iquique un
grupo de chilenos rechaza a los
migrantes que cruzan sus fronteras
no impregnaron de inmigrantes ancianos
enfermos
ignorantes y hablando idiomas
si primero una caridad empieza por pasa
con un chileno que está en el trabajo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
manifestantes quemaron tiendas de
campaña y pertenencias de los
extranjeros que acampaban aquí
dicen que la situación para los
nacionales ya es difícil como para
acoger a los que entran a diario a su
país y piden que se vayan
ilegales se vayan de esta ciudad se
vayan a su ciudad a su país donde ellos
corren donde gente legal gente de verdad
que necesita trabajar acá y expuestas y
proyectarse alguien iquique iquique es
la primera gran ciudad después de pasar
perú o bolivia y algunos migrantes la
eligen como la primera parada antes de
viajar a la capital oa otras regiones
un descontento que se evidenció durante
varios días pero que no todos comparten
la primera vez que vengo acá así que me
quiero acercar a la plaza muchos para
ver cómo la gente
[Música]
bandera de nuestro patriotismo sur
y derechos humanos la migración repito
es un derecho humano
delincuente como trabajo
en santiago activistas pidieron al
gobierno respuestas claras para atender
las necesidades tanto de los migrantes
como de los locales ocurrió en el norte
también se debe a la negligencia del
gobierno al haber permitido que las
personas se instalarán de esa forma en
la ciudad en colchón en iquique sin
contar con las necesidades más
elementales cubiertas con un trato
sumamente indigno entonces todo eso fue
contribuyendo a lo que ha ocurrido
nosotros esperamos que ésta sea una
oportunidad para asumir el tratamiento
de la migración y el refugio con mucha
responsabilidad
el gobierno ha tomado medidas para
controlar los ingresos en las fronteras
pero enfrenta desafíos para atender a
sus habitantes y a los migrantes que
llegan al país
las críticas de defensores de derechos
humanos al gobierno piñera se basan en
que ha centrado su política en el
control fronterizo pero ha dejado de
lado políticas de integración lo que al
final se evidencia en el sentimiento
hacia los migrantes hasta que
inmigrantes de france24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]